life in the micro cosmos is tough for
its unicellular residence prokaryotes
and protists have to compete for food
and space while also trying to avoid
organisms that are more than happy to
see all of their complex energy filled
biological bits as an afternoon snack
and managing those tasks can be even
more daunting when you are very very
small so instead of facing all these
challenges alone many of these organisms
treat survival as a team effort
[Applause]
as cells divide they adhere to one
another building a colony that becomes
larger and larger with every cell
division an individual cell can only get
so big before its size comes at the
expense of other abilities but a colony
can get much bigger providing protection
against predators and a competitive
advantage when it comes to finding space
and food and as the cells come together
and organize a colony can enable
organisms to do so much more than they
could on their own it's an advantage
that became a vital step on the path not
just to more complexity in the micro
cosmos but also a vital step on the path
to us but before we get to that let's
check out this long green thing cutting
across the screen maybe it looks like a
blade of grass rudely floating in
everybody's way but if you look closer
you can see thin filaments made up of
individual cells of a freshwater
cyanobacteria called a phenomenon often
times the names of these little
organisms are really a pain to say but a
phenomenon is just a joy if these cells
were on their own they'd basically be
little balls of candy just waiting to
get chopped but these long grass like
structures make it harder for filter
feeders like water flea to eat the Afeni
Zama non colony in lakes and ponds these
grassy structures can accumulate
creating dense visible blooms that
release toxins into the water
[Music]
nah stop colonies are also made up of
filaments like a string of beads where
the beads are cyanobacteria but where a
phenomenon likes to keep its strands
elongated nah stock wraps its filaments
around a structure made mostly of
different types of sugar that it
excretes to create a round gelatinous
mass these colonies vary in size but
some particularly large ones have been
measured with a diameter of 22
centimeters I realize I said that like
22 centimeters is very big but it is
when you're talking about a colony of
single-celled organisms nah stock use
sunlight to make their food but in the
process they also produce oxygen this is
a problem because nah stock also likes
to fix nitrogen from the air to make
necessary chemicals and oxygen
interferes with a key step in that
process but living in a colony means
that some of the gnostics cells can
specialized developing a thicker
exterior that prevents oxygen from
getting inside the cell these
specialised cells are called heterocysts
and they can focus on fixing nitrogen
without any worries of intruding oxygen
while the rest of the colony can
continue photosynthesizing
bacteria aren't the only species that
form colonies these spiked circular
creatures are pseudo PD astrum bori
annum the colonies are flat and the
cells are arranged in concentric circles
around each other where the a phenomenon
and Gnostic colonies we showed you
earlier seem to be full of cells strung
together the pseudo PD astrum colonies
are usually made up of 8 16 or 32 cells
whose walls contain a spore opala ninh a
hardy material that protects the cells
from the environment the gold algae
Sonora also forms colonies with
individual cells coming together like
little yellow marigolds each cell is
encased in silica scales and has two
whip-like structures called flagella
which tumble the colony through the
water when Steiner is bloom they can
turn a whole pond yellow letting off a
smell that is somewhat hard to describe
but even if you can't see the pond you
will definitely be able to smell it
this Ghanim colony is made up of several
flagellated cells arranged in a sphere
it may look simpler compared to some of
the other colonies we've seen but with
the rest of its evolved Essene algae
relatives it may hold answers to how
multicellular life evolved members of
this genus are either unicellular or
form colonies that through evolution
have increased in complexity from
species to species like this you dureena
colony whose structure is more complex
when compared to its predecessors like
gan 'i'm the you Tarina colony is made
up of only one type of cell repeated
around its surface but these colonies
created the structure that would serve
as the evolutionary stepping-stone for a
species just on the edge of
multicellular plio dureena which
contains specialized reproductive cells
and then ultimately to the definitely
multicellular Volvox
algae like the colonies before it Volvox
is built around a gooey transparent
matrix and like pleiad arena it contains
a set of specialized reproductive cells
just a tad bit more specialized those
smaller green spots are somatic cells or
body cells they don't reproduce or
divide and one of their main jobs is to
help move the colony using their
flagella but after a few days when their
duty is done those cells die meanwhile
on the inside are the larger gonna dia
cells which drive asexual reproduction
and might be immortal now remember the
Gnostic colonies that we talked about
before they also had elements of
specialization with some cells devoted
to nitrogen fixing and others devoted to
photosynthesis
the difference between gnostic and
Volvox however is that Volvox reproduces
by creating multicellular daughters
inside of it
the gonna do cells divide creating a
kind of baby Volvox with all of the
somatic cells and gonna do cells it will
need as it matures it's an organism
inside an organism and when they're
released
it is not cell division it is birth
another example of how when you look
very very close every sharp line turns
out to be blurry the colonies that
assemble in the micro cosmos are
important not just for the survival of
the organisms that comprise them but to
us and our understanding of how our own
multicellular existence came into being
whether bacteria or algae the way these
colonies come together and the shapes
they take on can be as distinctive as
the individual organisms they're made of
they make life in the micro cosmos just
that much more complex forming the
foundations for multicellular life both
under the microscope and beyond thank
you for coming on this journey with us
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want a new
video like this in your subscription box
every week there's got to be a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
you